okay next one
after two two stupid losses
now let's play the soy and at least
the pawn is lower rated this time
okay sicilian
he goes for knight c3
and the grand prix attack
i forgot all the theory of course
this is what i say remember this
was supposed to be okay for black
let's just play some aggressive moves
okay right now has won a pawn
yeah i need to open this up further okay
c5 is hanging but
what can you do
hmm
yeah this is two pawns down
do i have any compensation maybe rook b8
try to take on c4 and b2
maybe in it in this position
i forgot i think i forgot to play a6
here in this line
i'm still wondering why i'm two pawns
down
i think i need to play a6 first to
prevent the form yeah
well something to take into account next
time
okay i'd like to play 97 not
maybe he just has got bishop d4 then
and still it's not obvious
how to get some play here
don't see any other move
it's just two pawns
bishop d4 i wanted to play f6
maybe
yeah but well what can you say
it's two pawns
i'm not sure what you're thinking about
right now because this is
what would other move
you know white could play something else
i'm not
threatening much now as long as he
covers e5 yeah
this is playable of course
still the other move would have been
much simpler
maybe i can take now take now queen g5
threaten g2 and e5
he could he could play queen f2 though
it's still awfully bad
maybe take with the bishop and then
queen g5 i cannot
think all day here it's a correct
position anyway so
we can place queen f2 now
i intended to take here with the knight
to cover f7 but
it looks very shaky um i have seen this
one
a little bit too late unfortunately i
cannot take e5 because of knight d7
knight f6 of course
okay take here and take e5
and let's hope that he's got a
really bad end game play
if he exchanges that is that he doesn't
need to
necessarily
at least he's playing
almost as slowly as i am
no i need to take
okay maybe f5 gain some space
the only positive thing about this
position is
that the knight on d7 keeps the pawn
nicely blockaded
and i have some possibilities maybe to
to activate the king quickly
to e6
at least i've got some some bypass pawn
now
nc4 is hanging check
okay yeah let's play
let's play play active here c4 is still
hanging
let's take this off he already misplayed
that i think
this was um a lot better
at the beginning
okay let's get this pawns going
the night now is blockading both
pawns check
check
now i don't want to capture really
one person this is
oh let's retreat
okay
maybe open up the h file
check
okay but i can i can cover this
he's just got seven seconds left
let's go for for the d5 pawn
white forfeits on time okay it was a
time when
from from a completely
lost opening position
yeah actually in this position
i think i need to play a6 first then
knight retreats to c3 and then
knight f6 and
here it's questionable if i get
enough of anything for the pawns
yeah this is just lost with good play
but somehow
yeah this still should be okay for white
it's not the best he could achieve but
it should be okay at least
after this is already getting getting
a bit unpleasant for white i think
because
the pawns are not worth so much and
i also have some some play with my two
extra pawns on the king side
this should be already okay but okay
it's difficult to play with low time but
white already spoiled much of his
advantage